[Música]
la piel es el órgano más grande de todo
nuestro cuerpo y desde los inicios de la
evolución siempre la hemos llevado
puesta nos ha protegido del sol del
clima y de las bacterias es tan popular
que entre los animales se le puede
encontrar en todas las texturas y
colores que hasta las frutas tienen una
la naturaleza nos ha enseñado que se
puede vivir sin cerebro pero no sin piel
ahí tenemos a las esponjas estrellas de
mar que carecen del cerebro pero vaya
que están vivas pero qué es eso tan
especial que tiene la piel que nos ha
hecho pasar de peludos monos a pelones
miembros de la sociedad
pongamos de otra manera en que se
parecen un neurocirujano un escultor y
un bebé en que todos aprenden a través
del tacto el tacto es el elemento base
de la realidad es el que nos permite
saber cómo y dónde nos encontramos
realmente es el que le da significado a
los otros sentidos si no pudiéramos
sentir dónde estamos parados no
podríamos saber la ubicación de lo que
se encuentra a nuestro alrededor y por
ende no nos podríamos mover o de
cimiento de aquel que se haya levantado
corriendo cuando se le entró una pierna
de todas las habilidades que tenga la
inteligencia a mi parecer la que nos ha
hecho evolucionar más es la emocional y
no hay nada más emocional que un beso un
abrazo o una bofetada en la cara
de esta manera la humanidad logró
desarrollar una civilización con un
lenguaje muy abstracto basado en sus
sensaciones quien no ha escuchado la
frase ponerse en los zapatos del otro
por ejemplo con los artistas que se
desarrollaron en el contexto que
vivieron o más bien que sintieron por
eso fueron capaces de hacer obras
maestras únicas e irrepetibles y si
hablamos de tecnología si no te has
quemado electrocutado o explotado no has
vivido la ciencia jamás
enfoquémonos más en el tacto y su uso en
la vida del ser humano el hombre y la
mujer tienen cinco sentidos está
comprobado que el primero en
desarrollarse dentro del feto es el
tacto cuando nacemos lo primero que
queremos es abrazar a nuestras mamás
para que nos alimenten cuando esto
sucede nos sentimos más en confianza y
protegidos por nuestras mamás siendo
esta la primera relación que tenemos con
otro ser humano
luego crecemos somos infantes empezamos
a explorar ya tocar todo lo que nos
rodea
si nos lastimamos lloramos aprendiendo a
través del dolor lo que debemos de
evitar para poder sobrevivir y si nos
sentimos mal vienen nuestros papás para
llenarnos de caricias y abrazos tiempo
después en nuestra niñez empezamos a
socializar con otros chicos de nuestra
misma edad a maneras de juego de
contacto donde los golpes y las
cosquillas generarán todo un lenguaje
corporal que nos forma la personalidad y
nos da una idea sobre la realidad
vivimos
pasa el tiempo somos adolescentes donde
todo te pone de cabeza estamos llenos de
energía y nuevas sensaciones en nuestro
cuerpo nos visitan a conocernos como a
conocer a los demás
estas nuevas sensaciones nos ayudan a
moldear nuestra sexualidad o mejor
conocido por los cuates como a quien
quiero tocar y a quien le dejo que me
toque
ya adultos una vez que queremos tener
suficiente experiencia y una mejor
perspectiva sobre nuestra relación con
los demás nos dedicamos a buscar pareja
o más popularmente conocido como la
persona a la que más me gusta tocar
con la cual se hace un nuevo bebé y
dentro de todo ese proceso déjenme
decirles que hay una cantidad tremenda
de contacto
demostración perfecta de que sin el
tacto el círculo de la vida jamás se
hubiera completado
yo en las múltiples clases que he tomado
aprendí que la práctica te permite
entender mucho mejor las cosas y
practicar es solo sentir lo que haces
repetir el mismo golpe la misma
pincelada del mismo paso de baile todo
para poder aprender a sentir tu cuerpo y
así controlarlo pero todo cobró más
sentido cuando tomé clases de meditación
y de yoga donde controlar cómo te
sientes es fundamental
el tacto es muy importante nos permite
una comunicación pura no solo de ideas
sino también de sentimientos e
intenciones es curioso que si esto es
así y las señales están por todos lados
porque no le damos la importancia que
merece
pienso que el caso más preocupante se
encuentra en la tecnología donde hay
cada vez más descubrimientos
sorprendentes computadoras cuánticas
robots humanoides realidad virtual hasta
parece que nuestros celulares
evolucionan más rápido que nosotros
mismos pero no creen que les hace falta
algo que los haga sentir más reales más
humanos imaginen computadoras con tacto
que pudieran sentir en lo personal me
sentiría más seguro ya que algo como una
revolución de las máquinas como esas que
vemos en las películas sería más difícil
que ocurriera
robots contacto que pudieran sentir
dolor dudarían de hacernos daño por
temor a que se los dé volviésemos porque
como decía mike tyson todo el mundo
tiene un plan hasta que recibe un
puñetazo en la boca
debido a esto y otros factores se creó
una rama de la ciencia llamada óptica la
cual se encarga de estudiar lo que
siente el tacto así como tenemos la
óptica para lo que vemos y la acústica
para lo que escuchamos esto empezó a
desarrollarse en los setentas con una
propuesta un poco interesante una
pantalla donde pudieras sentir una
imagen en vez de verla esto se basaba en
las vibraciones que uno puede sentir en
la piel de esta manera se trató de armar
un aparato que generara vibraciones en
varios puntos de la espalda creando así
una imagen dependiendo qué tan alto o
qué tan bajo vibrar a cada uno
algo como los píxeles en las pantallas
de los antiguos videojuegos que solo
eran puntos de luz que se apagaban y
prendían dándonos una sensación de
movimiento
pero la falta de tecnología la
complejidad de lo que es representar el
tacto y una carencia de optimismo sobre
para qué iba a servir en el futuro hizo
que su desarrollo se parará por un
momento
y llegamos a nuestra era la tecnología
ha dado un salto enorme todo lo que
tiene que ver con luz y sonido están más
que desarrollado nuestras pantallas 4k y
sonidos 3d son tecnologías de punta y
agregarle más a su ya ultra alta
definición no sería de utilidad para
ningún ser humano
la industria de los videojuegos se dio
cuenta de que una realidad virtual donde
solo puedas ver y escuchar se volvería
aburrida ya que carecería de la esencia
básica de la realidad de esta manera
resurge interés en nuevo en el estudio
de la óptica donde la capacidad de poder
simular todo lo que sientes es una
ventana infinita de posibilidades no
solo para industrias como la realidad
virtual sino también para dispositivos
de navegación
por ejemplo la nasa está invirtiendo en
esta clase de tecnologías para sus
futuras misiones a marte donde los
astronautas serán aislados en un viaje
sin retorno y la falta de contacto
humano podría volverlos locos haciendo
que la misión fracasa se sólo imagínense
aislados del mundo que conocen en un
ambiente tan hostil como el espacio u
otro planeta y con el peso de la
humanidad en sus hombros con todos
estrés cualquiera desearía más un abrazo
de sus seres queridos no queremos
pero no nos vayamos hasta el espacio
para algo tan complicado como lo que es
la soledad si aquí en la tierra nos está
sucediendo aquí no le ha pasado que en
la hora de la comida o en la cena en una
fiesta
el amigo o la amiga están con su celular
hablando con otra persona sobre qué
aburrido está todo porque nadie está
interactuando con nadie
no me había dado cuenta de la
importancia de la app tica hasta que
junto con un amigo los pusimos a
trabajar en el desarrollo de una
prótesis de mano y dentro de toda esa
investigación descubrimos que las
prótesis ya están más que desarrolladas
robótica mente y una razón crucial por
la cual no vemos personas en la calle
con sus piernas o brazos robóticos es
porque los que lo necesitan lo sienten
como un estorbo por el simple hecho de
que si no puedo sentir lo que toco con
mi mano robótica no vale la pena mucha
gente a la que se le ha ofrecido esta
clase de tecnologías prefieren más usar
su muñón que traer pues un objeto que
aparte de caro es un peso extra
comprobé esto manejando de camino a casa
donde vi a un anciano que estaba
raspando la pintura de una pared para
poder retocar la pero lo impresionante
fue que él no tenía un brazo y todo lo
estaba haciendo hábilmente con un
cuchillo amarrado a su muñón
créanme o no pues lo primero que pensé
fue porque no está usando su mano
izquierda me tomó tiempo razonar que a
lo mejor él era diestro y se le hacía
más cómodo usar una
un pedazo de su miembro que ya sabía
usar desde los inicios
esta última cadena de sucesos quiso
llegar a la conclusión de que la óptica
es la pieza clave que le faltaba la
tecnología para desarrollar un concepto
llamado empatía
sólo imaginen computadoras que nos
puedan hacer sentir lo que los demás
sienten en lo personal me sentiría más
seguro ya que algo como una guerra o
hambruna como esas que vemos en las
noticias sería más difícil que ocurriera
no cree en medios de comunicación que no
se limiten sólo imágenes y sonidos para
representar una parte de todo el gran
abanico de pensamientos ya que si es tan
cierto que lo que nos hace humanos son
las sensaciones no deberíamos
encerrarnos solamente lo que vemos y
escuchamos
cuando las mentiras son capaces de
dominar nuestros ojos y nuestros oídos
ahí es donde debemos abrazar la realidad
y entrar en contacto con los demás y con
nosotros mismos gracias
[Aplausos]